After news broke that Ziploc bag
full of corn chowder
-Donald Trump... is...
-(laughter)
...skipping this year's White
House Correspondence Dinner,
'cause he doesn't have
to be there. Ugh!
So we decided on our show
to push for our old pal,
Anthony Atamanuik,
who's been doing
his amazing Trump impression
on our show for,
-like, a year now.
-(applause and cheering)
You can see the Trump-Bernie
debates on YouTube.
It was, like, one of the biggest
things we ever did on the show.
So we said, "Hey, maybe
Anthony could do this."
You know, to fill in
for the president
by promoting the hashtag
#MakeAnthonyTrumpAgain.
We even got the support
of Luke Skywalker himself!
-Mark Hamill jumped in to the
fray. -(applause and cheering)
This, of course,
trended on Twitter.
Seemed like everyone was
on board, you know.
Everyone, everyone except
for another Trump impersonator,
famous actor
and longtime resident
of your mom's mash cache,
Alec Baldwin.
(laughter)
Now for some reason, Baldwin,
who's doing an incredible Trump
on SNL,
and has been doing
an amazing job since last fall,
went on Jimmy Kimmel
and was kind of dismissive
of Anthony
and called him, quote,
"A guy who's on the Internet,"
which makes Anthony sound
like he's currently stuck
in Tron or something.
-(laughter)
-He's a real guy.
He's done a lot of stuff.
Anthony's an accomplished
performer.
He's been honing
his Trump impression since 2015,
a little bit longer than
Alec Baldwin, but it's fine.
-(laughter)
-I'm not trying to...
I don't want to battle anything.
I don't... you know?
Also, not to mention,
the two of them were
-on 30 Ro together for years.
Here's Anthony. -(cheering)
Now, this whole thing
spilled over onto Twitter,
where Alec was pretty dismissive
of Anthony.
And then, when a random fan,
and our friend James Adomian,
who played Sanders
in the Trump thing, jumped in--
admittedly,
Adomian was a little hot,
he was a little hot--
but Alec Baldwin responded
by threatening to sue them.
-(laughter)
-Wow.
The coups de grace
of this whole thing is
Alec Baldwin's twitter account
blocked @midnight,
a TV show,
and then (bleep) me!
He blocked me for some reason!
-(laughter)
-I didn't do anything!
-What did I do?
-(applause)
I didn't do anything!
I'm not a...
I didn't mean
to be part of this.
I... We were just supporting
our buddy, you know.
All right, first of all,
I wasn't following him,
-and he blocked me.
-(laughter)
But now I'm upset that I'm...
now that I can't follow him
if I wanted to.
I'm blocked.
Alec, I thought we were friends.
Look, this is your hand
on my shoulder.
-(applause and cheering)
-Look at this.
I didn't know.
I didn't even know
Alec Baldwin wanted to do
the correspondence dinner,
and we're certainly not (bleep)
on his impression in any way.
(bleep) both do it.
One of 'em
get up, and then roast the other
Trump, and then swap places.
-Who gives a (bleep)?
-(applause and cheering)
You know, we were just
rooting for our friend.
Tony...
Alec could just (bleep) do
the correspondence dinner.
If he wanted, he could just go,
"Hey, I want to do this."
And they go, "(bleep) do it.
Let's do it now.
Who gives a (bleep)? You're
Alec Baldwin. That's great."
Tony is the underdog here.
He is the Bernie Sanders
of Donald Trumps.
-Do you understand?
-(laughter)
-This is taking things
way too personally. -Wow.
Threatening people with lawsuits
and then blocking me,
-aka, you built a wall!
-(laughter)
-(cheers and applause)
-So, comedians...
I don't want there
to be any bad blood here.
What can I say to get
Alec Baldwin to unblock me?
-Steve. -Hi, Alec.
It's Lorne Michaels.
Could you do me a favor
and unblock Mr. Hardwick?
And while you're at it,
maybe make an appearance
on the Talking Dead?
Okay, bye. See you Saturday.
HARDWICK: All right, great.
Yeah, points. That'd be great.
-(applause)
-Thank you.
Arielle.
You don't need this.
You've got Alec Baldwin money.
-(laughter)
-HARDWICK: Yes, yes, points.
-(applause and cheering)
-He does.
-Flula Borg.
-Listen.
Of all of the Baldwin bothers,
you are absolutely
in my top three.
-(laughter)
-HARDWICK: See?!
-(applause and cheering)
-Alec, let's be friends again.